donc on arrête c'est ça ouais c'est
mieux non
le la est ce que tu veux bien qu'on
reste amis
ouais ouais ok mais
alors tu es stressé bah ouais un peu
resté ami avec son ex et pas et puis ça
fort souvent cool merci mec c'est cool
de se sentir soutenu c'est bien je t'en
prie tu l'écris non mais votre ami a
raison ça foire souvent ébats nickel
merci les gars vous m'aidez vachement
c'est cool
ouais tu vas en chier c'est gentil est
là pas par plaisir sa magnifique et la
maturité de rester amis etc son ex c'est
keita mais on n'a pas eu cette
intelligence la canton à niveau mais la
rfu tandis que vous soyez toujours pas
battu
moi aussi ma puce ou aussi
si nous sommes réunis aujourd'hui c'est
pour célébrer la fin d'une relation
amoureuse mais aussi la naissance d'une
amitié sincère
thomas bertrand acceptes tu de prendre
pour amie lola mariani de ne pas lui
envoyer de texto lui demandant de venir
chez toi le soir parce que tu te sens
seul et que tu es complètement bourré de
serrer la main de son nouveau mec sans
avoir envie de le frapper au visage et
d'être toujours présent malgré tout je
le veux comment tu va galérer chez lola
mariani acceptes tu de prendre pour ami
thomas bertrand de lui faire la bise à
plus de 4 cm de ses lèvres de ne pas
être jalouse quand tu verras la photo de
sa nouvelle meuf est d'être toujours
présente malgré tout
si quelqu'un s'oppose à cette union
qu'il le dise maintenant ou se taise à
jamais
moi je m'y oppose amandine mais c'est
qui tue sa petite amie n'a pas perdu de
temps mon [ __ ] c'est clair bon écoute
moi je suis pas chaude 1 pour que vous
restiez potes parce que
vraisemblablement vous avez vécu des
trucs très intime ensemble donc non non
non moi j'y arriverai pas alors je me
permets que la cérémonie soit
interrompue pour poser une petite
question comme tu es plus avec lola est
ce que je peux la drague et bob bof
attend commença babeuf bah ouais
pourquoi bof non mais c'est bizarre quoi
puis c'est loïc a vraiment envie de
sortir avec un mec pareil
non mais non est évidemment que non mais
enfin là c'est un peu abusé jeu social
que si on reste amis
t'auras pas donné son accord si je veux
baiser avec un connard du genre yes
en fait je suis juste là donc j'entends
un peu tout ce qui est un jury connard
tout ça bon thomas samsung alors sois tu
vas plus soit motion reste m alors
qu'est ce qu'on fait
et du coup avec elle d'ailleurs ce que
je propose c'est qu'on commence par elle
et après on finit avec vous ok ça se
complique quand même vachement la vie
les jeunes pardonne moi c'est moi que tu
parle évidemment à qui tu crois que je
parle depuis dix ans je suis habitué à
ce que tu t'adresses à moi en me
traitant de sac à merde donc j'ai un peu
surpris que ça va non mais tu trouves
pas qu'ils en font tout un foin pour
rien la mémoire courte
nous aussi on ne le fait toutefois quand
on s'est séparés genre quoi tu as quand
même essayé de me couper les burnes avec
un sécateur sécateur que m'avait offert
ton père pour mes trente deux ans c'est
bien que cela fasse marrer eh bien je
suis pris de panique à chaque fois je
passe devant un jardiland les ceignac
cette fois se marrer toujours présente
malgré tout je vous déclare pote par les
liens sacrés de l'amitié pouvez-vous
faire la bise
waouh on est sur une très bonne ambiance
là bon j'avoue c'est chez lui mais on va
s'habituer dans invasion on réessaie
notamment quoi moment hba ta main sur ma
cuisine dans la suite en disant c'est
encore sur console où on est d'accord
mais peut-être que c'est pas une bonne
idée qu'on reste amis
si on est plus amoureux et qu'on peut
pas être pote la solution c'est
peut-être de plus voir ouais mais tu vas
manquer à toi aussi tu vas manquer mais
au bout d'un moment on n'a pas dix mille
solutions si du coup on fait ça ouais
donc clairement on pouvait pas rester
potes
pourquoi pas parce que je sens ton des
réactions sur mon genou vont lui acte
ouais je tue bandai
qu'ils parlent maintenant ou se taise à
jamais je vous déclare pote par les
liens sacrés de l'amitié vous pouvez
faire la bise à votre ex
on attend que ça passe
l'amitié du coup alors elle est vieille
je suis jeune et plutôt beau gosse ok
mais est ce qu'il ya un moyen avec elle
ah ben je sais pas vous voyez avec elle
alors
bah oui évidemment le majeur
on